hey guys I'm out of the country at the
moment but we didn't want to leave you
hanging so here is a clip of someone on
MSNBC saying something completely insane
so Jamel the term woke originated in the
black community it's since been hijacked
by the right as we've seen but I
remember for example when black actress
Holly Bailey was cast as Ariel in The
Little Mermaid not long ago that was
decried as woke Runner Mark even though
that's not an example of hierarchies
being set up that's not an example of
free speech being silent so what that
tells me is that woke is often used by
conservatives as a way to complain about
black people and black activism
I mean it it's hard to deny when you
begin to see its actual usage not
necessarily by conservative politicians
but certainly by conservative media
figures by you know people in that orbit
and you see it you should describe a
black character in Star Wars a black
character and a a Disney movie
um you should see it describe the
commercial with an interracial couple
you do begin to wonder if it's just uh
you know a term of Art in this case for
saying you know black people who
shouldn't be there or black people I
don't think should be there kind of
thing
um and I think that is definitely Under
the Umbrella of meanings which gets to
the earlier point that it's just it's
just this this vague term of abuse that
can be used for really anything you want
to want to use it for other than
ironically its original meaning in the
black community which was kind of just a
being aware of
forces of Russian around you that's
generally what it used to mean but here
we are